my sister Alexis passed away last year
and Alexis was a great actor and had 70
credits and was really brave to live her
truth as a trans woman and they didn't
include her in the memorial and I think
that was a real slight to the trans
community especially at this time when
trans kids can't even go to the bathroom
in the United States of America at
school I think says a lot about the lack
of inclusion trans kids really can never
look at anyone and and see their heroes
and I think that was a big mistake why
do you think that happened do you think
it was just an oversight I think they
want to you know throw some cookies from
the ceiling I don't know it's it you
know I'm not surprised because the
reality is trans people are ignored all
the time in our culture in our community
they have their civil rights taken away
they're murdered beaten and oftentimes
they don't even end up having any kind
of justice you know the group that is
most likely to make the lowest amount of
money in America our trans women of
color who often live for under $10,000 a
year eight hundred dollars a month so
yeah they're a very disrespected
community
you
[Music]